I'm actually mca tonight I'll be
introducing the host of the night bed
lion and then presented a I'm Johnny
Galecki investing in a word Jose so we
talked to get your start how did you get
to host a TV show did you submit like
everybody else in Hollywood kind of on
actors access yeah you know it's
interesting because hosting jobs come
about the same way as acting job dude
yeah it's a breakdown express i have my
agents out there looking for stuff i'm
also an actor said things but I studied
broadcaster wow this is what you know I
how to do when I came to Hollywood I'm
happy that it to say that it Jordan yeah
we definitely do I'm just going to
everyone to give up there every time you
said you know it long ago never ever
ever did that cross my mind I came here
was no backup plan I think get all the
cover the back up plan or really sell
yourself short he gotta go all the way
you really want it there's nothing else
will make you happy and that's really
what it was for me I was happy living in
LA I don't I was probably doing
promotional right and he's 15 watch an
hour while I tried to follow my dream
that's more exciting to me than 50 gold
wishing i would all tried so that's it
for me don't give up no cuz people how
cheap as you love it thank you for
having me